Muy buenas tardes pues una manifestación
aquí en París que se ha desarrollado más
bien en completa tranquilidad hubo
algunos momentos con un poco de
detención entre la policía y algunos
personas que vinieron a digamos romper
un poco la tranquilidad la paz en la que
se ha venido llevando esta manifestación
con un muy buen ambiente una
manifestación multitudinaria se estiman
un medio millón de personas que salieron
a marchar en las calles de París de
hecho desde donde salió esta
manifestación tuvo que ser dividida en
dos para que la gente pudiera circular
mejor ya estamos un poco ya sobre el
tramo final de esta manifestación que
como les decía ha sido multitudinaria
aquí en París pero en realidad en todo
el país las cifras que se están dando a
conocer poco a poco por parte de los
sindicatos Pues también muestran que hay
una mayor participación o habría una
mayor participación de desde la última
manifestación que fue el pasado 19 de
enero y pues aquí las personas en todos
estos eslogans pidiendo que se retire
esta reforma pensional que tanto quiere
el gobierno de Manuel Macao y un
gobierno que además Hasta ahora se ha
mostrado que no quiere ceder ningún
poquito de terreno ellos se siguen
diciendo que esta es una reforma que es
necesaria que debe hacerse para que el
sistema vuelva a estar en equilibrio
pero las personas aquí consideran Pues
que es una reforma injusta y piden
finalmente Pues que esto no se lleve a
cabo personas que además muchas personas
que ya están jubiladas algunas personas
que están por jubilarse también han
venido acá hemos visto de todas las
generaciones estudiantes también que
consideran Pues que viene algo muy
Injusto porque les tendrán porque
tendrán que trabajar durante mucho más
tiempo para tener una pensión completa
Natalia no es la primera vez que los
franceses salen en masa a rechazar este
plan de gobierno en las calles francesas
háblenos de los puntos más importantes o
más polémicos de este proyecto
Bueno lo principal es precisamente es
ese aumento de la edad pensional de 62 a
64 años esto quiere decir que la gente
tendrá que trabajar al menos 43 años si
quieren tener esa pensión completa de
las que les mencionaba pero Incluso en
algunos casos habrá personas que tendrán
que trabajar un poquito más incluso
hasta los 44 años ya dentro de los
puntos digamos más centrales y más en
detalle esta reforma tiene que ver con
lo que es la penosidad del trabajo una
reforma que para muchos no tiene en
cuenta Eso personas que hacen trabajos
duros por ejemplo los obreros que
trabajan en construcción no se tienen en
cuenta esto pero también las personas
que tienen carreras largas que
comenzaron a trabajar desde muy temprano
antes de los veinte años personas que
hasta ahora podrían digamos retirarse o
jubilarse antes de los 60 años y ahora
tendrían que esperar a los 62 por
ejemplo para poder lograr ya Eh pues
tener una jubilación Así que estos son
algunos de los puntos también el caso de
las mujeres las mujeres que por lo
general tienen una pensión menor mucho
más digamos importante que la de los
hombres tienen carreras también que de
algunos momentos han tenido que
detenerse para poder Cuando han decidido
tener hijos y esto también pues las
penaliza y en esta reforma a pesar de
que el gobierno dice que tienen cuenta
mucho más esta esas situaciones en
realidad no es tan así así que estos son
digamos los principales puntos que
causan pues bastante escozor en esta
reforma pero sobre todo el hecho de
tener que trabajar más y los franceses
el 70 por ciento está en contra de esta
reforma según un último sondeo